Welcome, everybody!
It is time for Drew's News,
your daily news corn on the cob,
covered in that good news butter.
(Ross chuckling)
And with me at the desk,
my trusty co-pilot, Rossi Ross Matthews.
Nom-nom-nom-nom-nom-nom. Hi everybody!
Hi!
(audience cheering)
Corn on the cob. Ooh.
Stick around to the end of the show,
because today, guess what day it is Rossi.
My favorite day.
Pop quiz.
Yes!
(school bell ringing)
(audience cheering)
That's right.
I do love pop quiz.
One lucky audience member is gonna be in the hot seat.
We'll ask you three questions about today's show,
and if you get it right, you get $1000.
All right? So pay attention.
(audience cheering)
I love pop quiz.
And we don't even know what the questions are gonna be.
So you have to pay attention to everything.
I always play along.
Oh, me too,
and I'm always proud of myself
Me too.
when I know the answer, even though I was there.
(Drew laughing)
(Ross laughing)
All right, well, first up,
this story really speaks to me,
and I'm excited to tell you about it.
So the Oscars are a month away,
and this year, the 94 year old show
is trying something new.
"Variety" reports that fans can now vote
for their favorite movie of 2021.
That's right.
You can vote on Twitter
(audience cheering)
or the Oscars website until March 3rd,
and you can pick any movie
that you think was the year's best.
Results will be announced live, on the stage, on the Oscars.
(Drew exhaling)
I don't even know where to unpack this bag,
but why this hasn't happened sooner.
I love this.
You see millions of people writing in
for the "American Idol"s of the world.
Fan participation is a wonderful thing.
I am so excited about this.
Me too. Listen, I love the Oscars.
It is my New Year's, my Christmas, everything.
I love the Oscars,
but there are some years when what's voted on as the best,
doesn't really reflect what audiences are gonna go see.
So I'm on board.
I mean, girl, can I get a time machine, go back to 1989,
and vote for "Steel Magnolias"
over and over and over again?
(audience cheering)
Because that-
Drink your juice, Shelby.
Don't talk about me like I'm not here!
Juice is better.
(Ross laughing)
Yes.
I agree.
I also think, in this new modern era,
don't be archaic and so snooty-falooty.
Let's get the fans in there.
Absolutely.
And it's a way to honor,
like for example, this year "Spider-Man",
you know there was a lot of,
did you guys see,
I mean everybody on the planet saw "Spider-Man".
(audience cheering)
There was a lot of buzz
it could be nominated for "Best Picture",
because it brought so many audiences
out to the theater again.
It missed it, but here's a chance,
and I think that's probably the leader.
Don't you think? For this fan voted award?
I feel like it might get my vote, for sure.
Oh, that's a good question.
Is Drew Barrymore gonna go to Twitter and vote?
I absolutely am.
I love the Oscars, but I always felt like
some connection to fans and movie goers was missing,
and this might be the piece I've been waiting for.
Yeah, I think they finally figured it out. 94 years.
Hi, great job. Thanks, Oscars.
Sticking it out.
So, the results
will be announced, live, on the stage,
at the Oscars on March 27th,
and I gotta tell you,
I will always watch every Oscars,
but this year, I will be
really excited for this.
I know.
And I guess I now am an Academy member,
'cause I'm voting.
Yeah, exactly.
We all are!
Yeah,
when they say "Thank you, we'd like to thank the Academy".
You're welcome.
(audience applauding)
All right, next up, for you Drew,
showbiz is a family affair,
and that's true for the Apatow house, too.
You know director, Judd Apatow,
he put his daughters, Maude and Iris,
in his movies for years,
and now Maude's all grown up,
and she's starring in "Euphoria",
which is like the most
buzzed about show.
All the rage.
Well here's some more news,
"People" reports that the Apatows are,
you know, they like to kid around with each other,
and when Maude recently posted
about the latest episode of "Euphoria",
here's what Judd replied.
Her dad said,
"I'll watch it right after I finish 'Yellowstone'",
which I know is your favorite show.
(audience cheering)
I love it so much!
Well, I have news to tell you,
you know it takes me a minute
to decide whether I'm gonna binge a show,
because it's very serious,
right?
And I've been telling you,
please binge "Yellowstone".
Well, I want you to know that I, today,
pushed download on season one,
and so I will be starting it on the train today.
"Yellowstone", you may have just converted me in that way.
(Ross chuckling)
Well, buckle up, Matthews.
Buckle up, okay.
And then we can
talk about who's more exciting and appealing,
because they all vie for first place.
It's so fun.
(bright music)